warmer weather of course has some people
heading to lake mead but the colville
bay boat ramp is closed and the national
park service has advice for boaters joe
moeller reports now from lake mead
water level is now so low here at lake
mead that the national park service has
put a lock on the gate at the colville
bay boat launch ramp boaters we talked
to here say this is a concern for the
season absolutely beautiful when the sun
is out the water is the place to be i
live in eureka nevada gary cloyd has
been making a five hour drive from
eureka for years been down here for
a little over 12 years kloyd who is a
gold miner says this is his escape if
something goes wrong with the boat i
can't get it out
right
or i'll have to pay to have a toe over
to one of the other marinas he docks his
boat here at caulville bay due to the
water level being low the national park
service closed the boat ramp the other
marinas are going to be backed up
everything else at the marina is open
the only closure is the ramp the
national park service is urging people
to think ahead this season because they
expect longer than usual wait times at
other ramps with this closure
i didn't get alarmed about the ram being
closed until i seen that sign for it
jeremy webb hasn't been here in a few
years he was surprised just seeing how
much water has gone since i mean the
past just two years it's
it's alarming and pretty uh pretty
serious the other ramps are in operation
they are boulder harbor temple bar south
cove and willow beach our slip's 500
bucks a month floyd says paying to keep
his boat in the water means less time
waiting at the ramps my tips rent a slip
despite the ramp closure cauville bay is
still very much open the boat rentals
the restaurant and fuel are all still in
operation reporting at lake me joe
mohler live local now